-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
-Thank you. I appreciate that.
It was, uh...
quite a week we had, uh,
a big week for a death in--
in... (LAUGHS) ...politics.
One week, Rosalynn Carter,
uh, Henry Kissinger,
and the first woman
on the Supreme Court,
Sandra Day O'Connor, all--
all went to their reward
in the sky.
And we also lost, uh,
George Santos.
(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
AUDIENCE MEMBER: Bye, George.
But he-- he just went
to Abercrombie & Fitch.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
But, uh, yeah,
Congress finally did it.
-They kicked him out. Uh...
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING)
-Okay. I mean...
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
He'll be fine.
If it's one thing we know
about him,
he knows how to write
a resume.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-Um... No, he was... (LAUGHS)
...he was something different,
that George Santos.
Uh, a gay man
and a compulsive liar.
Uh, I called him
a fabulous fabulist.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
No? All right.
And he did not... (LAUGHS)
...he did not go quietly.
Did not--
when they kicked, he said--
Oh! He said, "Congress,
you wanna know
about Congress?"
He said, "This place
is full of felons galore."
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
By the way, "Felons galore"
is also the name he uses
when he does his drag show.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-"Felons galore."
It's a great name.
No, he was mean.
He's called the... (LAUGHS)
...head of the Ethics Committee
a pussy.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-He did.
And he also said, "Congress,
I'll tell you about Congress."
He said that,
"There's people in here
with all... all sorts of
sheisty backgrounds."
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-Sheisty.
And Marjorie Taylor Greene
says, "Sheisty.
I'm not sure what that is,
but it sounds anti-Semitic.
I'm in."
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-Um...
Well, let's uh... let's see
what's going on
in anti-Semite news.
-There's...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
There's so much of it, you know,
with the kids today. (LAUGHS)
"The progressives"
who love Hamas.
-Um...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
Yeah, they protested
that-- this week,
uh,
Rosalynn Carter's funeral.
I don't know what that had
to do with it.
Also, the lighting
of the tree,
the Christmas tree
at Rockefeller Center.
The pro-Palestinian people
protested that.
"No Christmas trees.
That'll teach the Jews."
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
I, uh...
(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
But the big thing
that I got excited--
Did you watch the debate
last night between...
-AUDIENCE: Yeah! (APPLAUDING)
-Okay.
I guess it got
higher ratings here
'cause we had one
of the participants in it.
It was California Governor,
Gavin Newsom against
the Florida Governor,
Ron DeSantis,
and, boy, did they take
the gloves off.
Ron DeSantis kept saying,
you know,
"California must be bad
because people keep
leaving it."
Uh... Have these people
ever tried to park here?
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
I don't think people
are leaving, not enough. Um...
No, he said,
"California's a failed state
because of the the leftist
ideology."
And Newsom was having
none of it.
He said, "No, no, no, no.
No, we're just a big tent
under the overpass."
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-Um...
No, I'm telling you,
Newsom is good.
You can't get him down.
I mean, he turns everything
into a brag... (LAUGHS)
...about California.
At one point,
did you see this?
DeSantis took out a map
of San Francisco showing
where all the shit
in the street is.
I'm not kidding,
that really happened
at a debate.
And-- And Newsom was like,
"Well, that just means
California has
the most fertile pavement
in the nation."
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
Very impressive.
But you know what,
at the end of the day,
nobody's mind was changed
about anything, right?
These things never do.
What's gonna make
the difference?
I'll tell you what's gonna make
the difference.
Gavin Newsom is 6■3■
with a smile like a movie star.
-(SMACKS LIPS)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
And DeSantis
is 5'10" in heels...
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
...with the forced smile
of a serial killer.
Okay, so...
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
So, you-- you may not think
that's what's gonna make
the difference,
but I'll tell you this,
at the end of the night,
DeSantis' wife left with Gavin.